Nick just got his new camera the a7s we
showed it last time but it's supposed to
be the low-light king of cameras right
now and I really want to test that out I
want to compare this low-light King
camera with these cameras that I use
every single day in an environment like
this but with less light that's a pretty
dark there go sit on that chair over
there so the lowest that your camera can
go you know there of us can see anything
is 1600 so I have to go up to 3200 5000
I'm starting to see the limit of the
couch still darker than what our eyes
can see
let's go up I'm at 10,000 okay I'm at 10
what can you see oh man let's start are
you at 5 6
mm-hmm okay I'm just gonna keep going so
I'm gonna go 12 twelve eight hundreds
where I go that's the top yeah one
hundred two thousand one hundred and
twenty eight thousand one hundred and
sixty thousand ISO two hundred and four
thousand and this is still at 5.6
aperture right yes we're gonna keep
going 256 three hundred three hundred
and twenty thousand eyes so there's
Conor sit down so now we're like I'm
overexposed Jesus now I wonder what
it'll look like when we color it let's
see
so I sitting here pulling a little bits
of like glass and metal out of the tire
Oh
dear sir yeah so I've actually had
several of these little mini holes in
the past but this was a really big hole
well to be fair I've put over 1300 miles
on this thing and I'm not treating it
nicely it's fallen down mountains it's
gone through water that's it a mile is
how long have you had it not even a year
so not even a year it is mine how does
he get me so well
I even tried getting you not even 30
seconds before how is that enough to top
my mind I'm gonna get on it oh oh that's
a flat tire oh my god yeah that's I
can't even write it like that it'll hurt
it how do you feel tired by googling it
I know Obi you're really upset about my
tire too
I actually don't know what's inside the
wheel it's not slime because that's a
brand name we should cut it open and
find out what's inside bring into the
workshop and we're utility funds
definitely lock that you do
[Music]
you guys are messing with me sorry
he's away geez so look at the TV just
it's up straight yeah it's just gone
look at that drop them black go
fullscreen on that the TV is almost
cured wow that's nice day I mean this
isn't what you would want as you're a
material looking for us no but like if
you're making a dock and you've no
lights but you can see like it's
struggling what's deep my arm when I get
up dude that blue is just like bleeding
into my arm right there it's too dark
it's too dark it's probably there we'll
just put some blue there hey boss I
don't know where your blue Gus I'll put
it here
[ __ ] throne blue round what have you
learned from this even though you don't
need a light light it shuts up good
filmmaking
I fixed the hole you fixed it yeah I
just I took one of those classic like
flat tire plugs that you get it just
like an auto store this is like kind of
lumpy yeah it's a little lumpy so I like
to go up to this mountain behind my
apartment and this time I went up with
Clint and there's one section where
we're just walking along and this thing
weighs like 23 pounds so it's not
exactly light it's like
tiring after a while just kind of
carrying it like this try dressing on my
head's rested on my neck and it's like
wow this is like really easy yeah I get
my neck a little dirty
I made the mistake like I'd never had to
have this a before turned on so here's
like the sensor but I have my thumb on
the sensor now Matt imagine that but on
my neck that's still black that's what I
mean I can't scrub that out either I
honestly think I may have tattooed rub
her into my skin how do you fix a one
wheel tire when there's a hole in it
sure this would require me to put
another hole in this tire Carmike well
I'm not gonna just do that don't you
want to be helpful to the one wheel
community
don't you want all the one wheel riders
to know who you are
this this applies to any tire car tires
bike tires debbie wwg oog le coms
forward slash how do you do this - dash
- wouldn't you rather that people come
to the same an eco channel yeah and then
anything you lump anything is possible
I can't believe you guys are actually
trying to convince me to do this my
grandfather once told me do it one
[Music]
if you made me do we need a bigger bowl
no yeah they made me do it our flood kit
from a company called slime the tire
plug kit comes with like four different
items one that's a little like rubber
I'm gonna take one of these things I'm
gonna thread it through this hole here
and then put rubber cement all over it
and I'm gonna take this with the things
sticking through jam it into the hole
and pull it back out in this thing will
stick everything I noticed from what I
saw on a couple YouTube videos boom
fix that hole so whose idea was it to
film this point right here the
audience's fault not their fault for you
Hey
No so flight tests just uploaded a video
they took like basing you know the
classic racing drone frame and they
enlarged it like a hundred times to the
scale it's now it's just a giant x-wing
like flying drone this quadcopter whoa I
think he flips and stuff with it and it
sounds like an airplane I want to watch
that video just stay on this video watch
to the end and they'll automatically go
to the next one I definitely recommend
it flight test you guys are amazing